hello my name is Yan perf Co I work for
Wolfram research and today I'm going to
talk about cloud notebooks what you can
do with them and what we've been working
on over the past year
hello and welcome my name is yang I'm
the lead developer of the cloud
notebooks team from research and today I
want to show how to develop sort of a
whole application using the Wolfram
cloud and of course I'm a bit biased but
I thought it would be nice to make
extensive use of cloud notebooks to do
that there's many other ways how you can
create content and develop applications
in the cloud like form functions and API
functions and I think they're they're
very just very good stuff you know
they're very powerful but I think also
pretty straightforward to use in a sense
whereas with scout notebooks I think it
might be a bit surprising what all you
can do with them and so my idea was to
build a blog basically you could call it
a static site generator build with the
Wolfram language that takes some content
that in our case will come from cloud
notebooks so that's how us the blog
author would write your content however
you want and then it would take that and
also deploy it again as cloud notebooks
just in a slightly different form so we
want to add an index page allows you to
navigate from the landing page of your
blog to individual posts now we have a
navigation header and we'll also take
care of comments so that people can
comment on your on your posts and that
will be quite a dynamic aspect to this
so just to give you an idea of what we
want to build in the end here is the
final result header up here you have a
list of of posts you can click them
navigate around from one post to another
there's some comments so that's that's
we're gonna build here and again the
idea is that we go from what I call
source notebooks through the codes that
we'll talk
here to target notebooks and some stuff
around them yeah so it's gonna be quite
a deep dive into actual codes so please
bear with me what what do you have to do
to get started here um we need to decide
where to put all this in the cloud and
there's the concept of unnamed cloud
objects which you get by by default when
you just do a cloud deploy of a
manipulator or something but for
everything that's sort of more
persistent that you want to share with
other people and maybe update later
I really recommend using named cloud
objects so in this case in order to say
my blog and that will represent a cloud
object that lives in my home directory
on the cloud
I could use subdirectories here whatever
but this is not just representing the
thing under my door my home directory
and then so that's where the the blog
will be accessible in the end you also
need to decide where our content lives
so the source notebooks and to make it
easier just decided to put that in the
same directory under a subdirectory
called content and there is a communal
function file named join that also works
on cloud objects so if the first part in
the list is a cloud object and file name
join will create another cloud object
doing the thing that that you would
expect and this is a general theme that
you know might be a bit surprising but
it's good to keep in mind that various
file related functions also work with
cloud objects and just do the right
thing with them in the end we need to
make that an actual directory so or
something to keep in mind cloud object
itself the function is only the
representation or the sort of the
address of that object it doesn't mean
where it exists or not so you know at
this point it doesn't exist yet but one
side to create directory
now it will be actual directory and also
the parent directory will be created
automatically ok and then so we have the
source directory we don't have any
actual content there yet I could now go
and write stuff either in the cloud
directly or in my local desktop
Mathematica in this case I have already
a notebook there just in the same
directory as this notebook for the
presentation I'm just going to copy that
into the cloud and again I'm using a
function copy file that was originally
meant for files but now if the second
argument is a cloud object it just
copies the thing into the cloud another
way just to give you an idea to get
stuff into the cloud is of course cloud
deploy so if I do a cloud deploy of a
manipulate and then as a second argument
again a cloud object in this directory
then it will deploy that to the cloud I
can already click the link and that's
that's what it is and this is also
interactive now yeah so that's our
source objects and you can already see
that I've used this naming convention
here that I'm gonna make use of later
where basically say what the date of the
post is right in the file name and then
the second part is the actual title of
my blog post ok so given that we need to
decide what our target objects are going
to be and we'll almost keep the URLs the
same as the source objects we'll just
you know make them a little simpler so
we take the the base name there so the
name of the file itself from the source
object and then we remove any diacritics
we convert it to lowercase and then we
replace any spaces with dashes which is
what you would sort of expect in in
final URLs and I just like to point out
that here it's we make good use of very
nice features in the Wolfram language to
easily work with strings
and so on so we have all that power
that's this useful here to get the title
of a page we just extract the thing
after the last - basically so we have
these helper functions and yep then we
can start thinking about building the
index page where you can see all the
blog posts listed - to get to these we
just use a function cloud objects that
numerator all the objects in a given
directory this case the source directory
so that's the two objects I just created
earlier of course I'm only using a set
delayed here so that we can easily
reevaluate everything later and it will
update automatically same for the index
object that's that's where the index
page will live in the end and then we
want to build a notebook that
constitutes that index page so here it's
all about working with the symbolic
structure of notebook expressions so for
each blog post we want to create a cell
that has a hyperlink you know pointing
to the target with the typo that you
already have our nice functions for and
then we just need to wrap that in a cell
and there's a bit of boilerplate to
create actual box content and then we're
almost done for the next page we just
need to wrap that in a notebook head and
deployed it we're deploying means in
this case just using cloud export of the
notebook expression I tell it again that
this should use the notebook format and
to my target object and then I say that
the permission should be public because
I want everyone to be able to look at at
this page if you execute that given the
sources that we had before it will
create this page doesn't look very nice
yet but it does have the the two links
um no particular reason actually I think
I just wanted to highlight it you can
use both cloudy ploy would have worked
just as well here there's some times and
maybe did this is gonna change I'm not
sure if it's true anymore right now but
cloudy ploy of a notebook used to do
some sort of magic that decided if it's
not actually dynamic content it would
create a more static version using no
static HTML and that looked a bit
differently than an actual notebook so
basically if you know that you want an
action notebook then cloud expert is a
good choice so it's there right so you
have the page here
of course the links don't work yet
because we haven't deployed anything yet
at the target objects one thing I can
already show is that there's a good
reason I chose index dot and B because
that will allow us to even omit that
from the URL so I can just do that and
it will pick up index dot and be
automatically similarly to you know how
you have index dot HTML which would also
work by the way if you have a static
HTML page but it it does the same for
notebooks right so the individual posts
there's a bit more code here we need a
way to extract the date from a given
file name you know - that we had and
then we create a cell based on that date
because that's what we want under the
title of every post we want to show the
the Tate the date as a subtitle cell in
this case and then to add that again we
make use of the symbolic nature of
notebooks we just find the first cell
which is a title cell and
and we inject our date cell into the
notebook at that position it would be
many different ways to do that to
operate on these list like structures
but that's that's one you also want to
sell at the top where we can navigate
back and forth between posts so which is
a function that gives us the previous
one and the next one and then constructs
hyperlinks based on that similarly then
add that at the very beginning of the
notebook and then to assemble a final
note book we just call these two
functions and of course it depends on
the original notebook content that's
what the post will be all about and to
retrieve that we just use cloud get here
in general pout get is used to retrieve
any expressions from the cloud in this
case make use of the fact that a
notebook file is nothing but an
expression in the end and that so that
will give us a notebook expression and
be modified in this way then again to
deploy a single post we just used deploy
a notebook function from before these
were the little helper functions to get
the previous next one and then we create
a function to deploy everything but just
deploying the index page and the posts
and I would say that that's a that's a
very useful scheme in general if you
create a cloud application make sure
that you have one function that allows
you to easily deploy everything at once
so you don't have to worry about which
parts did I now update you know that
deploy the right things to the right
places just make one function and really
relying on the powerful from language
again that makes it very easy so now we
have and by the way I made it return the
URL and also the number of posts just so
I can see immediately what went on so
now we have everything here I can now
click on this page and as you see we
have the tired
we have the date which was not in my
original source notebook and I have a
link here to jump to the to the next
post takes a little bit load but yeah
there's the manipulate alright any
questions so far
next thing let's add a header to make it
more like a real website for that we can
be as creative as we want I just decided
we want a hyperlink to the main page
again and you can do some styling give
it a background and some some cell
margins so that's it look like of course
it also works in in the desktop front
end but now we're going to deploy this
as part of our posts by just setting the
docked cells option
that's a useful thing for anything that
you want at the top of the notebook and
that stays there even if you scroll down
in the notebook and also while I'm added
hiding any Cell brackets because that
seemed a bit odd here to have the
brackets in a published blog we just
changed the function that we had before
to deploy a notebook by now using these
these notebook options and then I'll
just redeploy everything so now you have
the header I can go here and click it
again to go back to the to the index
page alright
on the index page it still looks a bit
lame just having these single links here
so I thought it would be nice if we
style disappeared and also included sort
of a summary of each post on the index
page and to do that again it's just
working with the with the notebook
expressions so to get the summary we get
all the cell expressions out of the
notebook then delete the title cell take
up to three cells from the remaining
ones append that to the hyperlink that
you already had before no that actually
append that to the to the title cell and
then also add the the the read more
hyperlink at the very end of the of the
summary so that's a summary and then the
single index entry is yeah just the
hyperlink that we already had plus that
Plus did the summary so with that it now
Oh some cash in yes
Oh looks like this oh you're right
there's two read more and three cells
just as you wanted all right now always
probably the trickiest thing that the
comments all do want to deal with that
so again the idea is that there is an
input field on each page where you can
type something and press a button and
then it should be added to a list of
comments and of course you want to store
these comments so if you revisit the
page later there should still be there
here's a couple of ways how you could
store these you know you might think of
using a single cloud object containing a
list where it just dumped stuff into it
that and that would probably work well
enough for most
but it does have a problem with race
conditions if two users that pretty much
the same time would make a comment it
would try to write to the same cloud
object at the same time and then one
would probably override the other we are
thinking about locking mechanisms for
cloud objects in general that would
prevent that but for now it just
wouldn't be the best idea other options
would be using cloud expressions but
that's still a rather experimental
feature and I would not recommend it for
anything that you know could grow very
large and that you don't want to lose
and also you might think of a database I
think there's great integration coming
for databases in Wolfram language so
then you could connect to a database
server but for now that is what I
decided to do is just to store each
comment in its own cloud object very
simple solution we just have to decide
on one directory where we put all that
stuff in this case it's going to be
inside block directory on the comments
and then there will also be a
subdirectory for each post and then the
individual comments will just be cloud
objects in in that directory so create
that and then this is I think the
longest function here it's just fits on
that screen what do we have to do for
the comments it's gonna be basically a
single cell that contains a form I don't
mean a form function here but it's just
an input field and a button we can see
that here there is an input field with
dynamic so I have access to this
variable and then the button just says
at the comment what whatever to use it
just typed all around this is a dynamic
module which on the one hand localizes
all these functions that I'm defining
here and that and by putting the those
functions into the initialization and
make sure that whenever someone opens
the notebook and the dynamic module
appears that these functions are
actually available you can't assume that
the kernel already has these predefined
somehow they need to be defined when you
open the notebook and on the other hand
we keep this sort of local state here
namely that the list of comments and
then when you when you add a comment so
that's this function we basically just
append to this list of comments and what
we store here is just an association
that keeps track of the text the author
and the date and then as I said we also
stored it in a file in addition to
changing what's displayed in a notebook
right now so for that we just create a
file name again using file name join I'm
you know just creating a random name
here because it won't matter in the end
for the individual comments and I'm
using a serialization here expression
JSON which is no just a very general
format that preserves all the preserved
expression as such right
then what else to render a single
comment we just use a panel and then
this is where it gets interesting so too
it's just a cell that shows the form but
you only want to show that if the user
is logged in so want to keep track of
who posted which comment and if they're
if they're not logged in yet we want to
make them log in using their wolfram
account and then we can just use dollar
requester wolfram ID to know who they
are and you know if they log in we show
the form but if they're not logged in
then we want to show a link saying that
you can log in to comment and then below
the
just render all the comments so how is
this how does this work and this reason
I'm showing is I think this could be a
useful technique for various cloud
applications how do you make sure that
the user is logged in or Austin to log
in otherwise you can deploy a separate
API that makes the user login using our
you know Wolfram provided authentication
mechanism you do that by deploying an
API function or in this case it's it's a
URL dispatcher but it's almost
equivalent that has permissions only for
authenticated users that will ensure
that when anyone tries to open this
cloud object we ask them to log in first
and then redirect them back to the
object now in this case we want one more
redirect because we don't want to the
user to stare at an empty page after the
login so the the login API itself just
makes another redirect back to the
original posts that the user came from
ok there is two redirects potentially
and how do we know where they came from
it's just gonna be part of the URL this
is a bit tricky and a point I'm gonna
explain in too much detail but
unfortunately I can't use an API
function with the query parameter here
because that would kind of get lost on
the way as it redirects back but it can
preserve the the base URL so I'm just
now constructing a URL that has the
target as part of it and that make sure
that then our authentication page
redirects back to this URL dispatcher we
we get the same URL again and then we
can just redirect based on that URL so
that's the login API and then similarly
as before we have a function that adds
that whole comments thing to give a
notebook under section
evaluate this No and then we tweak the
function that we had before that creates
a single post but just adding the the
comment section deploy this hope this
works
comments here we have our input field
type something press comment yeah days
so it knew that I was already logged in
and so I just posted it if you try the
other route
if I sign out now why this happens but
but go oh wait did I not hmm they do not
make this public in the first place or
okay let me try one thing that's
interesting maybe that's a bug actually
maybe I maybe I should have set the
permissions on the directory as well
yeah so if I if I access the index page
directly that that works even without
being signed in and now as we see
detected that gives us the link to login
that will redirect to the general
authentication page and no and then it
wasn't even noticeable but it redirected
page back to that login API now back to
the original blog post and now I could
comment here Oh a good question
I think there's something with caching I
know if it's a browser cache reason but
I think the browser key
the cache if it redirects and then back
all right so that's comments a few more
maybe slightly advanced things that you
might want to do to apply more styling
to notebooks a useful thing is notebook
style sheets so a bit similar to CSS
style sheets on the web but in this case
we're telling the front and how to style
a notebook and we're doing that using
another notebook so there's this special
format with you know style data cells
you can say that the text style should
have certain options in this case we
just say that any text should use this
particular font and then so this feature
we added pretty rather recently to have
support for for notebook style sheets in
the cloud you can simply deploy the
style sheet or just copy it to the
clouds however you want you just need to
make sure that the permissions are as Li
at least as open as the notebook that it
will be using the style sheet because
otherwise people would open a notebook
and they might not be able to open the
corresponding style sheet and then it
wouldn't work so in this case we just
set it to public and then to to use it
we again change to notebook options that
that is used for every that I use for
every notebook we deploy as part of the
blog and we just referenced the style
sheet using this syntax so if we deploy
now okay fresh notice but slightly
different font now of course I could
have done all sorts of stuff where I
could change all the colors maybe the
spacing of things and so on
okay but maybe that's not that doesn't
cover your use case or maybe you already
are familiar with how to write your own
HTML and your own CSS and at least for
some things you prefer to have that full
low-level control over you know how your
HTML should be and you can absolutely do
that in a notebook as well so what I
show here is how to embed HTML as part
of a notebook that just makes up a
single cell and then the rest of the
notebook is is regular notebook content
again so for our blog let's switch out
the header basically and it's going to
look very similar to before just a link
to the to the main page again but in
this case using HTML and also CSS that I
wrote before so to give you an idea how
that looks like it's just some piece of
CSS it says background and so on which
you also need to copy to the cloud and
then instead of the doc cells that we
had before we now have a cell that
contains embedded HTML but usually very
important with embedded HTML and it's
unfortunately not documented well yet is
that often you need the image size
option by default it will try to figure
out automatically how large the the
content is going to be but that doesn't
often work very well so it's usually a
good idea to just say what you want in
this case I want it to span over the
full width and just have a height of 50
pixels right the rest is just boil a
beta I also don't want any margins in
that cell to really have the HTML make
up the whole thing all right refresh
again yep can tell by the hover
this is now using our custom HTML that
we wrote if we look at this in the the
browsers dev tools you find that HTML
code again and it's also good to keep in
mind that I never use that it is
actually using an iframe to isolate
things from you know the notebook world
from the HTML world not least for for
security reasons it does not know I mean
it doesn't crash everything but what
will happen is I think you just get a
button that so if I do I don't know
just blink sound a thing anymore but no
what happened is I got a button that
allowed me to open that in a browser
that's I mean obviously you would only
use that if if you're targeting the web
a notebook is good enough and I think
for many cases it is good enough then
just use notebook constructs if you want
to use HTML then that will only work on
the web I think this might also change
at some point there is some ideas of how
to integrate WebKit into the desktop
front and then it could potentially
render this but right now that's just
not working all right and then this is
getting even bit more advanced but some
people have been asking about this so I
thought I'd show it so this is about
interacting with notebooks from other
websites it could be either from
embedded HTML inside the notebook and
you want to you know click a button
there and have it affect something in
the notebook or maybe from an outer
website where you embed a notebook that
just shows a bit of content like maybe a
manipulate but outside you have your
whole website that maybe you already
have or building so you want to be able
to kind of reach into the notebook
somehow and also
maybe in the other direction get
something out of the notebook again for
that I prepared a separate notebook
while I was working on this I did
unfortunately discover a few bugs I mean
most of it would still be working but I
had to fix something so this is now
using my local private cloud and there
we have this notebook
so yeah this in a few weeks this should
also work on the public cloud or all of
it so let's start with the direction
where you want to control the notebook
from some JavaScript code let's say in
in embedded HTML so what we have here is
embedded HTML that contains a button and
cause a function and in this case we
want to open or close a cell group and
we can do that by calling this function
so this is autumn so this is
automatically provided for any embedded
HTML and any JavaScript inside there you
have access to a Wolfram that cloud that
parent notebook which is the notebook
containing this piece of embedded HTML
and then there's a function they are
called evaluate expression and you can
just give it a string that execute is
more or less arbitrary piece of Wolfram
language code and then there is again a
multi-language function that opens or
closes a cell group so then that's
that's all we need here
yeah we just inject the definition of
that function in this case to make it
more convenient I will show how it works
in a more general case as well so just
to demo dad if I now select this cell
and then press the button it will open
and close the group that's containing
this cell okay there is a sort of caveat
to that this only works
this is what we call a safe expression
that can either evaluate right on the
client side because I believe that this
doesn't even have to go to the kernel it
will actually evaluate right in our
JavaScript evaluator but if it needs to
go to the kernel for let's say some
complex math operation and it's not
considered a safe thing then this
wouldn't work and the reason is that we
have a mechanism that so that the only
allow evaluation of expressions that are
contained in the notebook we don't want
a viewer of a notebook to be able to
execute arbitrary code that would
potentially run in the know the owners
kernel because when you deploy a
notebook it's using a kernel that has
access to your cloud files and so on and
obviously that would be bad if any
viewer could could execute anything so
if we want to inject the evaluation of
an expression from completely outside a
notebook we need to do some low-level
thing to sign an expression which adds a
signature and then the client will be
allowed to evaluate that expression in
the kernel so in this case if you want
to evaluate quit which is not a very
safe thing then we wrap it in sine
expression do some extraction of that
again and then should we get a string
that looks like this and then we can
feed that into evaluate expression so I
have if I use that in a bedded HTML and
now I press this button it quits the
kernel you could even see it down here
and the cell labels changed okay that's
going to address in your question as
well what if you don't use embedded HTML
or for every reason it you know this
doesn't get injected automatically then
you have to step one level deeper and
use what we call the JavaScript notebook
such API its relying on a JavaScript
mechanism called postmessage that is
responsible for passing messages from
one window to another that's usually you
know a containing page sends a message
to an iframe or the other way around
even though they might be from
completely different origins so they
couldn't just execute JavaScript in in
each other's context if you embed a
notebook then you know what that window
is you would someone have to get a
handle on on that iframe and that window
that it contains and then you can post a
message to it so that's that's the way
there's some boilerplate you say what it
yeah and versions own and then you use
this command and the rest is the same as
we saw before you just pass in an
expression that's all you need to
evaluate something if you also want to
get back a response which is interesting
in this case also for other API commands
you need you know you get back a message
to your window from the notebook window
so you have to add an event listener for
message events and then you can extract
the result out of there we could even
try this here so I'll open the the
JavaScript console in this browser and
in this case the the notebook window is
the window itself it's kind of the same
window talking to itself but it should
still work and so we computed sine of Pi
here and in the end alert the result all
right
this javascript notebook api has a bunch
of commands we only saw a valid
expression so far but there's things to
manage cell content and the selection
and so on it's not unfortunately not
officially documented yet but i think
we'll hopefully get to that soon and
yeah maybe
of course longer term maybe we won't
even need that many operations on this
level because ideally all you would need
to do is evaluate an expression
and since you can do everything in
Wolfram language itself in terms of
notebook programming that might be
enough anyway
all right
if you're still with me I can also show
the other direction what if we want to
send the message from notebook to some
JavaScript code that's again running
either outside of the notebook or inside
some embedded HTML in this case we have
a valid HTML that basically uses again
this window messaging mechanism so we
install a listener and when we receive a
message we change a counter and update
what's displayed here and it just came
up with this function called post
message that does just that so in this
case button when I click it simply sends
a message to all the iframes that were
created by embedded HTML and the
listener inside can pick it up very low
level of course but if you're
integrating notebooks into some website
that might be just what you need
similarly you can send a message to the
outer window so not the embedded HTML
things inside but something outside and
I should note that this function by
itself only works in again what we
called a client-side evaluator if you
want to execute it in a kernel
evaluation then you need to wrap it into
front and execute so I want to shift
enter evaluate this then with this
wrapper it will also work finally just
this one little thing we had this
function deploy that deployed our whole
page but I can make this as convenient
as I want for me so if I you know want
to edit my notebooks in the cloud and
then I want to update the whole blog
without even executing any code directly
anymore I could just deploy my deploy
function in a delayed
under a certain update URL and that
whenever so then whenever I open this
cloud object it will run my whole
deployment code takes a little bit used
to be faster but it should come back and
then again give me the URL and the
number of entries so now I could no
bookmark this page and just press it in
in the browser and and be done that kind
of makes use of a lot of magic of
Wolfram language under the hood again
right because it pulled in all the
definitions that that I made before I'll
wrap them up in a nice API and expose
that and also want to highlight you know
how how we've been using notebooks here
when you think about it really kind of
amazing that you still use them for so
many things we use notebooks to define
our original content that was no use to
populate the blog we use them as a
deployment target to kind of create
websites without really writing HTML at
all
I used notebooks when I when I wrote all
this code before we used notebooks to
define style sheets you know no we
created notebooks to style order
notebooks and of course we're looking at
a notebook here for this for this
presentation
so it's has many phases and the reason
it all works so well together is because
of this underlying symbolic structure of
notebooks that also integrates so nicely
into the symbolic structure of Wolfram
language itself which is kind of unique
I think this is online in a slightly
streamlined form on github and yeah you
have any questions let me know
Thanks
you
[Applause]